автори закону перука він вони державне
фінансування партій вище дозволити
зменшить їх плив олігархи в наполі так
ualign облазити Україну до Європи
багата краю через усі прочитаю факт ще на
сьогоднішній день повз ядро ​​жанру
фінансування partings f4 краї нах
tracktor один із західної Європи мальта
малака та швейцарія та 1 країна скидати
Білорусь і Молдова хурул так і закон все
брешуть нові закони та лиж і дозволити
партія мудрим і ви там не сумую червоне
порожній контроль за заздрістю Джирайя
фінансування про тему та дитинчата я про
успадкування європейських практик натиснувши
на фінансування партій йодом спабо
дружині євросоюзу для супроводу
безвізового режиму з Україною та проект
річки виносяться в зал на сьогодні з
продукт вже серйозна спільної роботи
українських та європейських x5uw європе в
великий вченого на так і не пузатих однак
розуміє, що державна фінансово не й
партії власне прохання вийти хоч
раз вже виду піку олігархію занатта
посмішку я їх не затікала ниткою у появі на
українську політичну систему для
успіху по три внизу або вбитих на
плівках я думаю їсти годинник потрібно
розглянуть і позитивно
alla yak вже було сказано цілий крок рок
про змінить вона багата bir shey контекст
падальщик року роблять і в нижчих
сферах
алани шато де cool і буде досягнута
критично масових терміни ви намотувати на
лижний хоча парламентарію хвали
законопроект чим 8 живий я президент
повернувши його у Верховну Раду і своїм
кит постом вище 23 листопада
зараз пішов на внесення правок їх і був
їх ванну з волосся і джипі годину друга вчить
вони я в парламенті те, що точний так
закону за ви вся на багату пісні шин не
сбу у проголосовані